oh
no
no
no
no no no no no no no no no no no
i do something in our guide to some of
the best most resonant black horror
movies we begin in 1960 with knight of
the living dead the movie was
groundbreaking for setting the zombie
template but also through its casting of
dwayne jones as it's hero in every man
of color he leads survivors through the
film up until its provocative ending
when director george a romero
inextricably binds the horror genre to
america's dark living history
today black horror is better than ever
jordan peele continues to elevate the
genre and more original films are being
released every year so get ready to get
scared because we're counting down the
best black horror movies all ranked by
tomato meter
[Music]
number 10 the people under the stairs
when young fool breaks into the home of
his family's greedy and uncaring
landlords he discovers a disturbing
scenario incestuous adult siblings have
mutilated a number of boys keeping them
imprisoned under the stairs in their
large creepy house as fool attempts to
flee before the psycho pass can catch
him he meets their daughter alice who
has been spared the discipline of her
deranged parents can fool and alice
escape before it's too late starring
brandon adams aj langer ving rhames and
directed by wes craven critics say held
aloft by gonzo black comedy and socially
conscious subtext the people under the
stairs marks a unique though wildly
uneven change of pace for director wes
craven we cannot see the bombers but the
fire of their munitions is shaking the
city it's shaking our hotel oh look look
there's a crew
there right over there it's flying just
over the roof
get back in there
number nine eve's bayou
over the course of a long hot louisiana
summer a ten-year-old black girl eve
batiste discovers that her family's
affluent existence is merely a facade
the philandering of her suave father
lewis creates a rift throwing eve's
mother roz and teenage sister sisley
into emotional turmoil eve though
manages to find some solace with her
quirky psychic aunt moselle starring
journey smallit lynn whitfield samuel l
jackson and directed by casey lemons
critics say eaves bayou marks a striking
feature debut for director casey lemons
layering terrific performances and
southern mysticism into a measured
meditation on delusion and forgiveness
what did you do to your brother i'm
going to push him out of the window if i
don't get out of this house
cicely's been in the
bathtub for an hour
you know that stayed in that three hours
yesterday unfortunately there's more
than one bathroom in this house ain't
that much dirt in all louisiana
get out of the damn tub you watch your
language young lady
mommy keeps stabbing herself in the
kitchen show her your hands mama i think
you better hush and where's daddy he's
never home
he's supposed to be home sometimes
listen you little and great
your father works hard so we can have a
house with four bathrooms not every
night he's not working i know he's not
um i mean let me buy you for a minute
number eight candyman 2021
in present day a decade after the
cabrini towers were torn down artist
anthony and his partner brianna move
into a luxury loft condo in cabrini now
gentrified beyond recognition and
inhabited by wealthy millennials with
anthony's painting career on the brink
of stalling a chance encounter with a
cabrini green old timer exposes anthony
to the tragically horrific nature of the
true story behind candyman anxious to
maintain his status in the chicago art
world anthony begins to explore these
macabre details in his paintings he
unknowingly opens a door to a complex
past that unravels his own sanity and
unleashes a terrifying wave of violence
putting him on a collision course with
destiny starring yaya abdulmatine ii
tiana paris nathan stewart-girette and
directed by nia decosta critics say
candyman takes an incisive visually
thrilling approach to deepening the
franchise's mythology and terrifying
audiences along the way
this is a story about a woman named
helen lyle
she was a grad student a white grad
student doing her thesis on the urban
legends of cabrini green
for research she came down to cabrini a
few times you know
asking questions taking pictures of
graffiti
people
and then
one day
she just
snaps
she beheaded a rottweiler
by the time the police show up she's in
one of the apartments doing snow angels
in a pool of blood
there's no way
go to rottweiler yeah this is extra even
for you there are articles written about
this look it up
number seven attack the block
south london teenagers defend their
neighborhood from malevolent
extraterrestrials starring john boyega
jody whittaker alex esmail and directed
by joe cornish critics say effortlessly
mixing scares laughs and social
commentary attack the block is a
thrilling briskly paced sci-fi yarn with
a distinctly british flavor
down the end
i'm too high for this
trust
you want to shoot those things man same
hair bruv time's free
don't know
number six sweetheart
after surviving a shipwreck jen the lone
survivor finds herself washed ashore on
an uninhabited island she spends her
days not only surviving the elements but
must fend off a sinister force that
surfaces each night starring hirsi
clemens emery cohen hannah mangan
lawrence and directed by jd dillard
critics say carried by keirsey clemens's
performance sweetheart balances smart
subtext and social commentary against
effective genre thrills
number five us
accompanied by her husband's son and
daughter adelaide wilson returns to the
beachfront home where she grew up as a
child haunted by a traumatic experience
from the past adelaide grows
increasingly concerned that something
bad is brewing her worst fear soon
becomes a reality when four masked
strangers descend upon the house forcing
the wilsons into a fight for survival
when the masks come off the family is
horrified to learn that each attacker
takes the appearance of one of them
starring lupita nyong'o winston duke
elizabeth moss and directed by jordan
peele critics say with jordan peel's
second inventive ambitious horror film
we have seen how to beat the sophomore
jinx and it is us
huh
who is that
oh it's a family y'all scared of a
family
a billionaire's family okay all right
enough enough of that
oh hey hey hey oh
what
zara give me your phone i'm not on sora
sorry
is there someone outside it's just a
family standing outside
it's probably the neighbors
you're kidding me hello my name is
adelaide wilson are you seriously
calling 911 right now
everything's good
all right i'm sure okay yes you know
what
what i'm gonna fix this
no we don't find out
what who they are no they haven't but i
know what we want and everything's gonna
be fine calm down okay no no no that's
too long oh boy
number four night of the living dead
a disparate group of individuals takes
refuge in an abandoned house when
corpses begin to leave the graveyard in
search of fresh human bodies to devour
the pragmatic ben does his best to
control the situation but when the
re-animated bodies surround the house
the other survivors begin to panic as
chaos begins to unfold within the group
the zombies start to find their way in
and one by one the living humans become
the prey of the dead starring dwayne
jones judith o'day carl hardman and
directed by george a romero critics say
george a romero's knight of the living
dead set the template for the zombie
film and features tight editing
realistic gore and a sly political
undercurrent
[Music]
hmm
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
number three the boy behind the door
a night of unimaginable terror awaits 12
year old bobby and his best friend kevin
when they are abducted on their way home
from school managing to escape his
confines bomi navigates the dark halls
praying his presence goes unnoticed as
he avoids his captor at every turn even
worse is the arrival of another stranger
whose mysterious arrangement with the
kidnapper may spell certain doom for
kevin with no means of calling for help
and miles of dark country in every
direction bobby embarks on a rescue
mission determined to get himself and
kevin out alive or die trying starring
lonnie chavez ezra dewey kristin bauer
and directed by david charbonnier and
justin powell critics say a tense
terrifying and all-around outstanding
feature debut for its co-directing duo
the boy behind the door should thrill
discerning horror fans
okay
[Music]
number two get out now that chris and
his girlfriend rose have reached to meet
the parents milestone of dating she
invites him for a weekend getaway with
misty and dean at first chris reads a
family's overly accommodating behavior
as nervous attempts to deal with their
daughter's interracial relationship but
as the weekend progresses a series of
increasingly disturbing discoveries
leads him to a truth that he never could
have imagined starring daniel kaluuya
alison williams katherine keener and
directed by jordan peele critics say
funny scary and thought-provoking get
out seamlessly weaves its trenchant
social critiques into a brilliantly
effective and entertaining horror comedy
thrill ride
good to see another brother around here
ah
yes
of course it is
something wrong
there you are
can you do something with this ah yes
yes
oh hello
i'm philomena and uh and you are
chris rose's boyfriend
you
fantastic
make a lovely cup
thanks
ah where are my manners logan logan king
chris was just telling me how he felt
much more comfortable with my being here
that's nice
um
logan
i hate to tear you away dear but
the wind cuts were asking about you
[Music]
well it was nice to meet you chris
goodbye
[Music]
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
candyman
skeptical graduate student helen lyle
befriends annie marie mccoy while
researching superstitions in a housing
project on chicago's near north side
from anne-marie helen learns about the
candyman a knife-wielding figure of
urban legend that some of her neighbors
believe to be responsible for a recent
murder after a mysterious man matching
the candyman's description begins
stalking her helen comes to fear that
the legend may be all too real starring
virginia madsen tony todd vanessa
williams and directed by bernard rose
critics say though it ultimately
sacrifices some mystery in the name of
gory thrills candyman is a nuanced
effectively chilling tale that benefits
from an interesting premise and some
fine performances
yes
who is that
who is that
helen
i came for you
do i know you
no
no
but you doubted me
i'm sorry i have to go
no need to leave yet
blade
a half mortal hunter is out to avenge
his mother's death and rid the world of
vampires the technologically advanced
vampires that he is going after are in
search of his special blood type needed
to summon an evil god who plays a key
role in their plan to execute the human
race starring wesley snipes stephen dorf
nebucha wright and directed by steven
norrington critics say though some may
find the plot a bit lacking blade's
action is fierce plentiful and
appropriately stylish for a comic book
adaptation
hey blade
[Music]
let's do this
[Music]
ma the lonely middle-aged woman
befriends some teenagers and decides to
let them party in the basement of her
home but there are some house rules one
of the kids has to stay sober no cursing
and never go upstairs they must also
refer to her as ma but as ma's
hospitality starts to curdle into
obsession what began as a teenage dream
turns into a terrorizing nightmare ma's
place goes from the best place in town
to the worst place on earth starring
octavia spencer diana silvers juliet
lewis and directed by tate taylor
critics say octavia spencer's
performance overpowers many of ma's
flaws but uneven pacing and a labored
story keeps this thriller from fully
realizing its unhinged potential
suanne how you doing today
i'm good
there are quite a few cups and bottles
in your yard right now and uh
a couple cars on the street part near
your driveway
is there anything you need to share with
me
are you serious i'm serious
must be some sort of
sorority prank or something i guess i'll
have to spend the whole day picking all
that up
[Music]
who's in this house with you sue ann
um is everything okay
my daughter is very sick and right now
you're preventing us from getting her to
a doctor's appointment
let's see
my apologies young lady i hope you feel
better
and finally number one his house
a refugee couple makes a harrowing
escape from war-torn south sudan but
then they struggle to adjust to their
new life in an english town that has an
evil lurking beneath the surface
starring woonmi masaku shopei dirisu
matt smith and directed by remy weeks
critics say featuring genuine scares
through every corridor his house is a
terrifying look at the specters of the
refugee experience and a stunning
feature debut for remy weeks and a path
has risen from the ocean
it has followed us here
it spoke to me
what did it say
we don't belong here
if we leave
and repay our debt
it would guide us back to her
to my gak
my love she's gone this he took her
you're not listening
english
listen to what you are saying he's
dead have grieved enough enough
there is no witch
[Music]
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of that
entertainment content you love until
next time i am your host naz perez and
we'll see you back here for more top 10s
on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you